hello and welcome to Intelligence
Squared with me Philippa Thomas today
we're going to take a wider view of how
the struggle in Ukraine is reshaping
World politics and we're going to
encourage you to consider the bigger
picture beyond the biggest Global
players Russia the US China to consider
what our guest terms the middle powers
like turkey or India our aim today is to
give you a more complete and nuanced
picture of what's happening in
geopolitics as it swirls around Ukraine
and we hope you'll help us in this hours
exchange by as was explained just now by
using Twitter by asking questions by
contributing your questions and comments
well I'm delighted to introduce Our
Guest here's political scientist Ivan
krushtv Ivan is chair of the center for
Liberal strategies in Sofia he is also
at The Institute for human Sciences in
Vienna and Ivan joins us today from the
Indiana let me just say he's a founding
board member of the European Council on
Foreign Relations and a contributing
opinion writer for the New York Times
and he has many books out out in English
including after Europe and the light
that failed where you can find out more
about his thinking but Ivan it's a real
pleasure to to meet you I've read you
but not met you before so it's great to
have the chance for us to have a long
conversation and kind of dig into some
of these issues uh I want to start by
saying that in the UK where I'm sitting
and in the US the tendency is to look at
Ukraine through the lens of Russian
relations with the US with NATO with
Europe a bit of a rerun of a cold war
Focus but there's much more to
understand and many more players to
factor in so if you would can we start
with an overview of your idea of how
complex this picture is
listen exactly basically how the world
looks like is very much depends from
where you see it
seen from Europe and particularly big
European countries United States this is
the return of the Cold War
the enemies they say there is a clash
between a democratic Ukraine and
authoritarian Russia
Russians when they started their special
operations that turn into the world were
trying to convince the world that
basically this is nothing this is just a
local conflict nobody else should be
interested and for the ukrainians this
is very much a kind of a National
Liberation War this is very much a
anti-colonial war
so interesting stories why all these
narratives are mixing and how we're
going to see the international order
appearing looking at them listen of
course it's a clash between democracy
and authoritarianism but unlike in the
case of the Cold War you're going to see
that many of the democratic countries
which
didn't Biden invited for the summit of
democracy we're not in a hurry or eager
to sanction Russia regardless of the
fact that basically Russia did something
that was clear violation of a major
principles of international relations so
while in Europe we were very much trying
to see the Cold War this country is
basically regardless of the fact that
probably they didn't like much what
President Putin did prefer to have a
different position and secondly while
many friends of Ukraine believe that it
is easy to go to the African countries
and India and others and said listen
this is a classical anti-colonial War
you should remember it it was not very
different to what happened to you many
of these countries were saying probably
but this is not our Empires
even more some of the Imperial Powers we
have been fighting against are now
supporting you so for me the biggest
story was then how to make a sense of
this new situation and what they start
to realize is that well of course post
United States and Russia and China were
trying to see this very much through the
prism of a much more Global picture you
have the rise of a middle powers and I
know the defining middle Powers is not
the easiest thing that can happen in the
world but it is either the size of the
country or economic or military power or
even geographical positions that very
much incentivize it empowered to use
this conflict to try to assert how
important they are for their regions how
important therefore it International
politics and from this point of view you
see India
very much classical biggest democracy in
the world going into a coalition with
the United States in other contexts but
totally unwilling to change its
relationship with Russia very much
benefiting from buying discounted
Russian oil you see turkey that is
trying to position itself much more in a
position of a mediator and trying
basically have a NATO member state that
is saying yes we support Ukraine but
we're not going to sanction Russia so
this pushed me to believe that while we
are trying to see the Futures the world
which is going to be shaped by China and
the United States that we're going to be
back to the kind of a new second season
of The Cold War we're seeing something
different and all these middle powers
for whom basically decolonization was
more important than the Cold War as
dying to use it and to in a certain way
both suffer from the crisis of
international order but also to enjoy
the new importance that they are getting
so even turkey is a great example I
think because rigid type erdogan wants
to be seen as a bigger leader globally
he wants to be of importance and perhaps
of use and so he's not prepared to take
a role that
American dominated NATO might want him
to he wants to Define things for himself
totally and this is the most important
because this middle Powers this is not
the kind of a third block
this is not returned to the
non-alignment movement all these
countries they are competing with each
other they're very different on the
level of interest on the level of values
on the level of political regimes but
what is important for them is they they
want to reassert First their sovereignty
their political identity but also the
importance of the relevance for the
international order and you see Mr
erdogan on that level turkey was the
country that was the first to give
drones to Ukraine on the other side
turkey was the country that said we are
going to host Russian ukrainians
negotiations turkey is a country which
is not sanctioning Russia and you're
going to see a lot of Russians and a lot
of Russian companies operating from
Turkey so this kind of a
moved in which I'm using this crisis to
say that I'm a sovereign power that have
my own interest and that basically you
cannot simply treat me as the NATO
member it's very important for turkey
but it's not only turkey given that the
Saudi Arabia one of the traditional uh
Ally of the United States basically
during uh the latest OPEC discussions
they much more came with a policy which
was beneficial for Russia they went for
a closer relationship with China and on
the other side of the same kind of a
process you have Russia's traditional
allies like Kazakhstan like uh Armenia
or Azerbaijan which are also very much
using this crisis not to stay
next to Russia but basically to say no
no we're different we have our own
interests we are going to play a totally
different game and we are not ready to
follow what Russia is going to say
so that's risky isn't it whether you
look at Kazakhstan and and the mighty
Russian bear or you think for example
about India which is enjoying cup price
Russian oil but you know has spent a
long time establishing better relations
with Washington and
to a lesser extent with London it's a
risky business saying
um are you playing both sides how are
you going to be seen by the biggest
powers
you're absolutely right and this is
interesting and the fact that in many of
these countries basically even when they
are not fully Democratic people are
voting it is a popular with the public
the idea that we're important that we
have sovereignty nobody can tell us
we're not simply alive of one power or
the other it is important for the Turks
it is important for the Indians but it
is also important for the kazakhs and
from this point of view the political
leaders are taking this risk the risk is
real because all this game this middle
power activism can also end up badly for
them but this is the new thing that in
my view we are missing when we're trying
simply to explain what is going on in
the framework of return to the Cold War
this is a type of behavior which was not
so typical for the Cold War this is a
type of behavior in which we have too
many countries which big enough powerful
enough in order to believe that they can
have these games and you said that it's
risky it is risky it is risky on the
other side it is popular and by the way
they're looking each other all these
countries are saying I can do it I'm
going to show to the Americans to the
Chinese that were important that
basically they should treat us specially
and the fact that I'm interested in my
own interest and nobody else is becoming
something very popular particularly
outside of of the West and this is
something new and this is something that
makes me to believe that well now
everybody's saying what the Americans
will do what the Chinese will do
probably the future of the international
order is going to be much more the
result of the activism of these middle
Powers which can differ strategies
different resources and the Americans
and the Chinese are much more trying to
basically keep the situation under
control than to act as a kind of these
architects of Last Resort
I will come to the Chinese but to to
focus on the Americans for the moment
this requires this reality requires more
sophisticated and more flexible thinking
um and I'm aware from my American
reporting of you know how much the U.S
state Department for example was beaten
down in the Trump years and I would like
your opinion on how ready or how nuanced
you think American
foreign policy makers can be at this
point
interestingly enough I do believe that
President Biden and his Administrations
were quite fast to adjust to this
situation remember just some months ago
he invited all these countries when he
basically started his presidency on the
summit of democracies and then he walks
around and majority of these countries
are not sanctioning Russia uh but what
the Americans are doing they didn't get
outraged they didn't tell to India if
you're not going to follow us we're
going to put your secondary sanctions
they're not telling the Turks what
you're doing is totally unacceptable uh
because you see that the NATO member
states like Poland and others have been
very much threatened by this war but
they try to see how they can use and
basically how they can arrange a
situation in which even if these
countries are not going totally to Ally
with them at least that they're not
going to play uh a game that is going to
be destructive for the American
long-term strategy and I do believe
these patience on the American side
which we didn't seen some other
conflicts this very different than if
you are not with us you're against us
worked well there was one case in which
I do believe that basically the White
House lost its nurse and this was after
the Saudi Arabia very much came uh with
a cut of fatal production and with the
policy that very much benefiting Russia
but in my view especially in this case
also the Biden Administration has the
right feeling that this was a kind of
early vote on the site of uh Saudi
leader in the midterm elections in the
United States so he said it as a kind of
a personal hostile act as a policy that
was very much meant you heard the
Electoral chances of the democratic
party on the elections but otherwise in
mind of the United States is much more
patient and much more understanding some
of these sensitivities and resentment
that you can expect knowing some
previous Behavior
and we will come on to what could happen
in the future in American politics and
and with other elections but just
looking at the the
Cowa centers and how you judge the way
they're acting on Ukraine what about
Brussels what about Europe This is a
conflict on their borders so many
Ukraine ukrainians have fled
um you see this uh you know from your
position how do you rate the way that
Brussels is reacting
listen for Europe this was a major shock
and this is something that people kind
of from time to time underestimate
particularly when they are not living in
Europe it's not by accident that the
most famous history of Europe in the
second half of 20th century Tony Judd's
book was called post-war
uh European project did not simply come
from the End of the World War II but
European project is very much rooted in
the fact that the new major war is not
possible in Europe anymore after the end
of the Cold War
Europeans we managed to convince
ourselves that economic interdependence
is the best way to secure the continent
we managed to convince ourselves that
military power doesn't matter and then
suddenly all this crashed in a day
and from this point of view European
reaction was either surprising to many
and European United States but this was
also very much the result of the
American position
and also this was very much the result
of the fact that suddenly
Europeans who have been before it quite
dismissive to the capacities and the
willingness of the Ukraine
to respond and to defend itself was very
much mesmerized by the Ukrainian Miracle
listen many Europeans most of the
Europeans exports and not experts while
being highly critical to what President
Putin was doing was sure that he's going
to succeed and in my view this was the
power of the Ukrainian resistance
created a moment which is very much
transforming Europe and this is what
happened and while this unit is there of
course you're going to see major splits
and kind of major differences both
between the countries and within the
countries the East West divide was very
much exposed you know very well that
countries like Poland or the Baltic
republics were extremely critical to the
way Germany and France have been
conducting their Russia policy in the
last year so from this point if it was a
Moment of Truth for Europe
talking of moments of Truth do you think
there's a potential parallel situation
with China and Taiwan
foreign
this is this is this is the interesting
story and this is the Paradox because if
you go before the war and particularly
if you see uh how the center of
international political geopolitical
gravity was moving from Europe to Asia
uh you can see that this war was a kind
of a strange War uh there is a lot of
speculations how much the United States
were interested and not interested in
the war but everybody who has been
following American politics he knew that
the dream of the Bison Administration
was to park Russia in order to be able
to concentrate on China and Taiwan
because obviously from the jail
strategic point of view from the logic
of the major competition between China
and Russia Taiwan was the critically
important
and this is by the way I was very much
convinced that the decision of the
American intelligence to start to
publish on a daily basis the information
that they have about the preparation of
the war was very much based on the
assumptions that President Putin coming
from the intelligent Services cannot
start the war in the absence of surprise
and they will signaling to him we're not
surprised we know what you're going to
do but the war started and now when it
started for the United States but also
for Europe the idea is that this war
should end the way to make the point for
China that in a certain way going to
Taipan is not a great idea so this is
why nevertheless that this conflict in
certain way is far away uh from Taiwan
it is very clear that everybody who is
trying to understand how the end of the
war is going to affect International
politics all the time is making the
parallels between Ukraine and Taiwan
and the only thing we know to expect is
to expect change the uh you know the
unexpected
Thai in Taiwan in in fact there are
several key elections coming up in the
next year or so and in Taiwan a kind of
a rise in nationalism could affect this
entire balance
totally this is one of the interesting
possibility for us to make sense of what
was going on normally when we're
thinking about 2023 we're trying to see
how certain trends that we have seen in
2022 are going to continue or going to
be disrupted but particularly my
understanding of the development of the
situation is very much run by the idea
that in order to understand 2023 we
should be able to see it from the
perspective of the 2024 and particularly
from the perspective of several critical
elections that are going to take place
in 2024 and which are going to affect
the policies and the conduct of the war
because this is the difference between
the wars and the elections we never know
when the works are breaking up we don't
know when they're going to end up but
it's we know when basically the votes
are going to be counted in certain
places so look at 2024 you're going to
have presidential elections in both
Russia and Ukraine
in March 2024 you're going to have
parliamentary elections most probably in
UK you're going to have European
elections for European Parliament you're
going to have elections in Taiwan in
which if you're going to have a
pro-independence candidate winning it's
really going to affect very much also
the way China is seeing not simply what
is happening in Taiwan but what is
happening basically also in Russia and
Ukraine and plus you have the American
elections which are going to be
critically important uh for the way the
American Administration basically is
going to behave with respect to this war
so in my view strangely enough ballot
boxes these days is quite often the
places where the war starts but also the
war ends
there is so much there I want to pick up
on some of those areas and I also want
to thank the audience because questions
are already coming in and I'm going to
remind you that we're going to leave a
lot of space for your questions and you
can ask a question by clicking on ask
question and remember tell us your name
if you want us to to quote you or to say
where you are you can also tweet about
the conversation that we're having I was
even crushchev uh using the hashtag iq2
but let's go back to elections on what's
coming up let's go to Russia I mean who
dares oppose Putin in any major sense is
he vulnerable politically do you think
listen interestingly enough of course
the popular saying is that there are two
things that you cannot choose in Russia
you're president and your parents but
what is critically important is that
while Russia is not a democracy
elections have been always very
important for the legitimation of
President Putin every elections was
serving to show the people that there is
no alternative to put in and on this
elections this is not simply is there
going to be a candidate I don't believe
that the elections are going to be
organized if Putin is running that he's
going to lose the elections but for the
first time President Putin is going to
be challenged not so much from those who
said why did you start this stupid War
but also those who are saying why you
are not winning this bloody war
so for the first time the criticism to
Kremlin are coming not simply from the
liberal sources but also from a much
more extreme nationalistic position
saying okay you started but why you're
not winning and this creates a moment of
vulnerability it also creates a moment
of vulnerability because Russian
population was kind of quite ready to
live with the idea of the Special
Operations something like the large
version of Crimea where basically the
Russian army goes succeeds in several
weeks and the people are just going to
cheer it in the way you're cheering as a
football team but now you have a
mobilization and probably you're going
to have a mobileization and probably
they're going to be more than half a
million young men that are going to be
thrown uh to the battlefield and many of
them are going to be killed this is a
different social contract and from this
point of view President Putin is
vulnerable and he should try to find a
way to explain to the Russians why this
war is taking place of course his major
narrative is that he's not fighting
Ukraine he's fighting the west but if
he's fighting the West what is the
Victory and in my view this story to
explain the people what is a victory and
why they should suffer is going to be
very difficult and this is why the
election campaign is a moment of
vulnerability and my feeling is that the
Russian leaders the Russian leader knows
very well this
and when we think about what leaders are
offering their people zielinski
is
popular of course he didn't flee he
stayed he's leading day by day but at
the same time he's Limited in any change
he can offer I'm I'm I assume that it's
going to be very hard for him to say
look we should talk to the Russians when
facing re-election himself
totally and from this point of it's very
important that for Ukraine first it's
very important to organize the elections
and listen it is not easy you organizing
the elections in a country in which the
majority of the population is not living
in the places in which they have been
living in the day the war started some
have been immigrated are they going to
vote some have been moved because of of
occupation and uh because of the
distractions so first and it's
critically important for Ukraine to show
the infrastructural capacity to organize
the elections and secondly of course
president zielinski is very popular but
present zelenski is very popular because
he's telling his own people I'm not
going to go on any compromise I'm not
ready to do any type of a territorial
concession the moment he said okay let's
see what kind of concession I can do be
sure that they're going to be another
candidate which is going to run on the
elections and saying no this is not what
we have been talking about you have told
to the people that we are going to
liberate all our territory and this
makes me believe that for the same
reasons we discussed about Russia and
Ukraine for both countries it's going to
be very difficult for us to have any
meaningful negotiations in 2023 and
secondly there is not good even
possibility for the conflict to freeze
in 2023 because in the elections in 2024
to a great extent of defining what is
possible and what is not possible and of
course what is happening on the ground
is the most important and in the wars
what is deciding decisive is really uh
uh what the armies are doing but this
kind of a very important constraints
match is very clear that president
zielinski is under strong pressure to
stay where he is and to do what he has
promised to do and to be honest this is
also true for President Putin who is
insisting we are winning this is our
land and so on and obviously he's not
winning at the moment but he should try
to convince his own population that he's
doing this so I'm saying this because
this type of a perspective from the
elections he's not going to tell us what
is going to happen but probably is going
to help us to understand what is not
likely to happen
it seems a long time until we get to the
U.S election even though we know the
campaigning starts pretty soon but even
looking towards November 2024 and a
possible return of trump or simply
return of a republican candidate who's
not inclined to fund and back Ukraine I
suppose that looms over Ukraine doesn't
it in the sense that without U.S backing
without that military backing
it's so much harder to keep going
listen uh Ukrainian Army is really
giving an incredibly uh uh impressive
fight but they cannot succeed in the
absence of American weapons and they
cannot success succeed in the absence of
the financial support coming from
outside
30 percent of the economy of the country
is destroyed basically there's cities
that do not function so from this point
of view this is critically important and
this is interesting it's not simply that
Republicans get said we're not going to
give you more weapons this is not so
easy to be done but during the election
campaigns uh what probably the
Republican candidate and by the way
nevertheless who he is will probably to
do is said oh yeah it's put in war but
it's also a Biden's War and President
Biden is going to be very strong press
not to allow two things to happen if
basically Ukraine is going to divorce
he of course is going to be under strong
pressure but secondly on the other side
the American public is not interested
the American troops to take part in the
war so this is why forbiden is extremely
important America to win Ukraine to win
but at the same time the Americans to be
sure that we are not moving to the World
War III so for all these players as I
was trying to uh to show the very
important constraints and very important
things that they want and they don't
want to happen just on the 8th of the
elections
let's bring in some of what our audience
has been bringing to the conversation
because they're very engaged and
actually there's a lot of questions on
your idea of the middle Powers
reasserting themselves and I think one
is so Bettina us for example do you see
the middle Powers grouping together
aligning and I think actually that's not
what you're saying is no but but do
explain listen I don't see them aligning
funnily enough they're also competing
very much with each other what they
share very much is the desire to be at
the table
because what middle Powers has learned
is that when you're not at the table
you're at the menu and this is what they
really want to change but at the same
time they're neither coming with a
common ideas outside of the ideas that
they're going to have and should play
much more important role note they are
basically sharing the same interests
because some of this middle Powers also
in a competition with each other and
this is the interesting story about it
as I said middle Powers is not the
return of the non-alignment movement
as you know some of these middle powers
are light Powers turkey is member of
NATO what is important for all of them
is to show
that their foreign policy is very much
formulated and very much decided in
their own capitals and they have the
capacity at least if not to shape the
world to shape their regions so you have
a lot of ambition you have a lot of
activism from time to time these powers
of course can end up with a certain ad
hoc Coalition on certain issues but
there is also a lot of competition and a
lot of mistrust between the Middle
Powers themselves for example for sure
Israel is a middle power Iran is a
middle power too turkey is a middle
power so even just in the Middle East
Saudi Arabia is the middle of power all
these countries you are not going to see
basically going together and enjoying
while in the same policy but the only
thing that is critical in the behavior
of the middle power is that they don't
believe that they're going to be benefit
if the world simply go back to the Cold
War as they knew it
a great question from Claire who do you
think will be the most important middle
power in the next 10 years
foreign